hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and this is fears to Fathom the second
episode in a series of games that are
apparently based off of true stories
that were posted on Reddit that's
something I found out episodic
psychological horror game where each
episode unveils the short story narrated
by the ones who survived you're playing
episode two more episodes are coming
soon boink
anything about hitchhiking and this is
the Norwood hitchhike is uh bad news in
horror games uh never turns out well
never goes well and usually ends up with
someone dying those are my predictions
for this game and we shall see June 16th
this happened to me when I was 19.
I'm a little over 21 now
I still remember this very clearly
because of how creeped out I felt
I was a bit hesitant to write this out
for the internet at first getting it out
may help
even if just a little bit I was one of
those people that loves gaming
conventions I go to Every convention I
get the chance to and sometimes even
meet some of my online friends
though my parents weren't always
thrilled at the idea of me going on
Interstate drives but a plane ticket
would have been too expensive this
convention I was at went great and it
was now the day to drive back home
when I set off I soon realized the
traffic was horrible I decided that I'd
take the long way to avoid the traffic
who was a little over 12 hour drive
oh I'm driving
I don't know if I should be trusted to
that
okay
God damn this is a disgusting car
is that Moss oh boy I don't know if I
should read my phone right now but here
I go
I see I'm rerouting gotta do what you
gotta do don't forget to call me
drive safe Holly
I'm apparently Holly
I have a funny feeling
that I'm about to run into some trouble
on the road and my car is gonna go
bye-bye
car's gonna go bye-bye
I'm really hoping that this is royalty
free music all right read my phone again
sure
where did you reach uh nowhere yet dad
uh still working on it
kind of going through nowheresville
oh no oh no you're halfway through the
drive I realized I was low on gas
uh oh
hi Dad I told you to take that flake
flight still about six hours away from
the city got stuck in a jam
yeah you know how it is oh come on dad
I'm about to go off the road
say oh Holly it's going to be late when
you reach back hope you're feeling all
right well
what was that
what did I just see in my review
looked like a face but I'm thinking it
was just
behind me
oh thank goodness a gas station
this is definitely not royalty free
probably
I hope it's on that side
all right boink boink
[Music]
hmm
hello I would like some gas please
pretty please
hello
hi hi how you doing sir
good to see you
can I get 10 on pump two
all right oh
hi Mom
you heading to the bridge by yourself
Bridge the Norwood Valley Road I mean
not a lot of people head down there this
time of year
be careful
what do you mean for about a century now
many people have gone been going missing
down there
some people who went looking for him
never returned locals say the Norwood
Valley monster torn them up and hung
them upside down on trees
well you think people would find
evidence of that you know
given that people were hung upside down
on trees
can I use the toilet it's not cleaned
well that never stopped me and I don't
suppose that the clean status of a gas
station bathroom is that good in the
first place
uh apparently you don't have any
uh you got pump two thanks
anything else ma'am
goodbye
where did that guy go he just wandered
through that wall
and one more thing
if you see a woman in white or blue gown
trying to get a ride do not stop
just step on gas as hard as you can who
is she some people say that she died in
a car accident from there on Prom Night
some say that she seeks Vengeance after
she was murdered there hi sir
oh
you didn't disappear through the wall
okay
regardless She's Out For Blood whatever
you do never ever under any circumstance
pitch a pick up a hitchhiker
those people are out there on the road
putting their thumbs out they ain't what
you think ma'am they just ain't
okey dokey then what are you doing
that's what I thought how are you doing
uh I'm a little closer than I wanted to
be but my God your shoulders are broad
okay you heard about the Norway Valley
monster the normal wave out the Norwood
Valley monster you know anything
big mistake
uh those are not going just looked at me
where are you headed
okie dokie then you have a good day now
it's gonna go pump some gas
hi Mom
Holly Mom I don't know if you'll find
any shop at this hour but we're out of
dog food could you get something from
Milo I'll pay you back oh fine
all right
dog food dog food do you have dog food
here gaboos is that dog food
dog food dog food maybe
yeah
I need this
that'll be five dollars man that's
pretty cheap dog food that ain't bad
thank you
don't think I bought more than one of
those
okie dokie then
uh
perfect
good enough
oh pump two
uh
this is pump one
three two one gas
I probably didn't need to move my car
I got an achievement I filled the tank
and I was off the row off the road again
I was off to that's a weird way to say
that am I gonna go off-road
hey hey beacon on the road you do
realize a thing
monsters truly do exist
yeah you [ __ ] and every single one of
them looks just like you and me
what
uh mom I am literally driving right now
is it not expired or anything I'm
assuming I said something about uh dog
food at the gas station you don't need
to pay me for it
when my lights go
my lights driving at night is really
therapeutic for me
there they are why did my lights go on
well at least it used to be bumpy
I'm getting that uneasy feeling the
question oh that's a problem whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa I'm not doing that
what is that all about
what are you doing there
hey uh car in front of me don't mind the
car freaking out behind you it's totally
fine everything's good okay
yeah you might want to run away from me
who knows I might be the uh Norwood
Valley monster
boy I can't see
oh what is going on behind me oh there
we go
well that's nice
okay
everything seems fairly normal
what is this sound do you guys hear that
it's like a rumbling but it's not part
of the engine oh there goes the road
okay
oh the bridge it's the bridge
I've heard about this bridge
not good things mind
why is it always bridges that have
horrible horror stories attached to them
something just terrifying about a bridge
it's against nature
whoa hey I'll admit I was a terrible
drug I didn't do that oh my God
I did not do what do you mean I'll admit
you admit I didn't do that
the hell
so do I pick up a hitchhiker if that
happens okay
uh
okay I seem to have somehow made my way
into a swamp and I don't know how that
happened oh hi
uh
what oh god hi
that didn't sound like a rabbit
I'm pretty sure I know what a rabbit
sounds like and that definitely didn't
sound like one oh second bridge nope
just some random thing
what did I say about no left turns
there's something very weird there's a
very weird thing about that night I saw
two big logs in the middle of the road
blocking the way ahead
huh
it almost seemed as if someone had
deliberately put those there
but I didn't think much of it at the
time
I'm not thinking much of this
I refuse to dedicate any brain power to
this
those are heavy
can I move them
I can
huh it did seem like there was a path to
go left over there but you know probably
for the best that I don't go exploring
in a horror game
that's how people get killed in horror
movies what what no
let go of it
this is super weird
okay that's one
what
hello
rabbit
okay that's fine
all right that should do it cool
oh
oh come on
oh God
oh God
car wouldn't start back up
why not
why won't this car start back up
oh
I'm The Hitchhiker and just like that I
was stranded in the middle of nowhere
with no cell service
oh boy
oh boy
with my shitty Moss infested car
but I would be lying if I say I didn't
feel the slightest of unease I don't
mean to make this sound like a cliche
horror story but throughout my life I
was told not to take rides from
strangers but at that moment I had no
choice
yep I'm The Hitchhiker I was scared to
think how long it would take for someone
to pass
what
why
10 23 P.M
okay
I saw a car nearing I did I do hello
please I'm not the girl whoa hey oh come
on
[Music]
Pure Evil
I didn't understand how somebody could
leave another human being stranded like
that
[Music]
maybe they were all told the story of
the Norwood Valley monster and they
didn't want to die horribly
anyone else
anyone
Bueller
Bueller
Bueller
hello please I need help I'm not a
monster I won't kill you I won't I won't
kill you I'm not gonna kill you I won't
kill you
hey you stopping
you're stopping hey hello hi you're
friendly right hi
oh I don't like the music
hello hi howdy hello there friend hi oh
you're the girl from the gas station
like thank you so much for stopping what
are you trying to do out here I think my
car just broke down I can't call for
help there's no phone service you think
I can get a ride
where are you heading to
just the nearest Stop where I can call
for help hop in thanks so much could you
wait till I get my stuff hurry up just
throw it in the back I won't be here for
too long okay you got it
you could back up a little bit and help
me
oh sorry I'm inconveniencing you with my
monsterness
whatever
only had two hands we gotta get the dog
food
I got priorities you know
hold on hold on my stuff
one more hold on hold hold
I suppose I could have gotten this out
beforehand but I didn't expect anyone
would actually stop oh my skateboard
hold on there
who you good enough one more can't
forget the skateboard and a hat
uh jump
ER got it all right I'm coming hold on
don't leave you literally have all my
possessions so if you leave here a real
[ __ ]
and oh there we go clothes are up all
right it'll be fine
hello
should I close it oh
y'all nope okay I'm ready
let's see uh oh I didn't ask I'm done
finally now hop in be quick all right
why
I'm in thank you
thank you sir
hi
okay thank you
so why'd you spend so much time at the
gas station
I don't see anything that you bought oh
so you won't tell me who you are where
you're going
I was driving home
and that piece of crap broke down on me
Jason what my name's Jason
I'm Holly
my real name is Markiplier but I'm not
telling him that you're really lucky I
had to be on this side of town tonight
and had to spend so much time shopping
at a gas station
I must say you are one Brave young woman
how's that
you got any clue what happened to your
car back there
let's see it's an old car that's it I
think so
I don't know what do you think
I'm pretty brave though so what do you
think about what he told you back at the
gas station
you really creeped me out
interesting
that response is interesting idiot tells
that to every person traveling down here
oh I guess I'm a jackass
talk so is it true what the Monster
let's see I've never seen the monster
for myself but there are
there are some things and I'm afraid
your car breaking down could have been
one of them Hey listen I don't want to
sound like that [ __ ] but just remember
this
you don't bother them and you don't be
bothered
who's them you know I'm sorry for being
a jerk to you before I'm not the best
with people
oh it's okay I could have said something
to that that's all right
nice enough now I guess
1208 am
well this seems relatively nice after a
little bit of small talk he dropped me
by a motel apparently they offered
roadside assistance besides I thought I
could use a little rest be careful there
are all kinds of people out there he
said ominously before leaving
I'm sure there are but you seem nice
enough thank you
thank you very much
okay I'll just leave that there then hot
[Music]
the man was putting out the creepiest
Vibes imaginable yeah I could feel that
also isn't this the guy from the gas
station
hi
gal needs a room to shack up for the
night
leave uh yes I'm only gonna be here for
a few hours
forty dollars for single pay cash only
room number nine right over there
[ __ ] bucket car ninety dollars Tommy
will take care of it next thing in the
morning
it's a lot of money
so I'm pretty sure my knowledge of
gaming conventions you blow all your
money at the convention you don't got
nothing but you do have cash sometimes
good I'll let Tommy know and one last
thing try not to wake the other guests
they might not take very nicely to it
okay thanks
who's this
right over there room number nine it is
okay
who's that same person okay bye uh
whatever
oh I might do I have any money left oh
consuming these items increases
oh how much money do I got
cheapest thing is the chocolate bar
it's only moderately concerning consume
I was too low on cash for that
apparently oh I am a little faster
I'm all hopped up uh hi oh there we go
uh hi
okay
well I can't wake the other guests
apparently I'll just go to my room then
it was nice and warm inside
except there was a smell a type of musky
smell you get from old houses
oh no
okay every time you go into one of these
you gotta check everything you have to
it's a murderer check it's very standard
check every room oh hi hello hi
how are you doing
what are you doing here I should be
asking you that
I'm Tommy room service here at Roadway
Inn the finest stop over in Norwood what
were you doing in there you know clean
and stuff sorry I didn't say that right
oh you know
clean and stuff got the front desk gave
me this room
I'm gonna have to ask you to step
outside while I make the room I'll just
get my stuff
um he's waiting outside I said go get
your stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
did you set me up for that sir got a
complaint
stuff is right outside I know where it
is
really needed me some energy soda
well I don't need it I got a chocolate
bar in me and that's all I'll ever need
oh isn't that lovely hi huh
had a word with Joe about this situation
what is wrong with these people Mercy
Mercy Mercy what why you I don't like
you but don't you worry it's safe here I
go get your car also the room's phone is
not working if you need anything just
ask the front desk we've been trying to
get it fixed but we haven't been seeing
enough guests lately
but you have a good night
yeah
oh but I didn't get all my stuff
I didn't do
kind of slow ain't ya
okay just gonna grab my hat and dog food
priorities you know priorities you know
Tommy I don't like you Tommy Tommy I'm
gonna be real clear with you I don't
like you
I don't like you tall oh at least it
looks like he's going to go get my car
right now
well that's awfully nice at least he's
not going to be here
okay I'm gonna go talk to uh
the front deskman because it sure seems
like something strange is going on
around here hi
you have a great night's sleep all right
I will I guess
okey dokey then not a proof for
occupancy
that's that's that strange
that's that's very strange how about
another chocolate bar you know just to
put me to sleep
yum it's like stacking can I get
exponentially faster
I think an envelope
that's hard to tell
okie dokie then
well
yeah that ain't no I don't know I'm not
allowed to put that in a video uh Lexi
and replace it with something uh very
royalty free
uh now that's quality content that's
this kind of stuff that I can really
appreciate I stand by this and whatever
this is
okay um I guess I'll shower no
I guess I'll sleep I guess
okay goodbye
um
yeah it don't work
well good night
well good night
oh God
oh God thank goodness that wasn't going
to be there the whole night I hate that
that's still oh
call it a foresight but there was
something very off about the place yeah
yeah my sixth sense is Tangled
I couldn't help shake the feeling that
something wasn't right hmm But I cannot
place my finger upon it the feeling
tiredness was Overcoming By anxiety
um you want to try that again
a hot cup of coffee could help I thought
to myself what was what was the deal
here
anybody outside my door
okay
yeah a hot cup of coffee help you sleep
that's that's what that's what we all
wanted oh is that a coffee machine over
there probably
yeah
this is fine consuming these items to
help you stay awake I know
I know how Coffee Works
okay
what happened
what happened
what's happening
oh why
in the oh no oh no
oh no
that wasn't coffee
oh no
everything's backwards by the way my my
entire control scheme is reversed
um
oh
okay
oh
which one was my room again here we go
okay just gonna
quick murder check every time you come
back he always check for murders
everything's backwards oh my god oh
my murderers murderers nope okay bedtime
[Music]
same things
I don't think you know how Coffee Works
game 3 18 a.m I was sedated
oh that's not supposed to be working
oh
who who just
who's in there who's in there oh oh God
supposed to do that was I ah
[Music]
[Applause]
are you serious
are you serious
are you serious
are you serious
oh I was about to say holy crap
oh
that's not the right time
oh my God
oh
why here you [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God why would you you almost
killed me why would you do that you son
of a [ __ ] okay I was just I was just
getting back to where I were
not there yet so we'll be back in a
little bit here's a smile for me to tide
you over in the meantime
hello sir ah you're skedaddling
huh
funny about that
funny about you being right there
I guess I'll just get myself uh
cappuccino
I'm going before it kicks in before it
kicks in no okie dokie then just gonna
do can't read that I know but okay
I am in bed
I am now back did you enjoy that smile I
know all right so don't open the closet
I should have learned my lesson from the
previous game at least it didn't send me
back all the way to the beginning that
would have been extremely unfortunate
I don't like that
phone's not ringing though
that's strange
why is the phone not ringing the phone
was ringing before and it's now ringing
now
don't don't
what are you doing
stop
no
I'm not gonna
semi door or is that something else
who is there who is that okay that looks
like
the manager why would I open that
I think I broke something because it's
not
who is it
Joe from front desk opened the door
why
why
would I do that
who is it
okay hi hello you didn't kill me didn't
I specifically tell you not to wake
anyone up
what
I have complaints what are you making
all those goofy noises for whatever it
is just keep it down Miss
is that why are your eyes all red into
the coffee machine
uh are you messing with me
we don't have a coffee machine
it's right over there okay okay here
I've had enough of you crazy goons for
once I thought we had a sober guest but
I guess I'm the crazy one here
I hate my job
follow me there was a coffee machine
right over here apparently and I'm
leading you to it and you're walking
very creepily towards me I swear
it was right here
uh
[Music]
well that's not good
I swear it was right here mister
hmm
[Music]
trunk is mysteriously open you could
hurry I'm like not doing while I'm still
moving faster than you
go back to the room
for some reason his demeanor completely
changed I swear to God it was right here
I said go back now
okay
there should be some medication in your
room that should offer you some relief
check the table by the TV okay there's
no one in my room right
okay
[Music]
requires water I don't want to go in
there
[Music]
well that's not working for some reason
oh
is there even a sink in here
is there a sinking a drink out of the
tub
thank goodness that didn't kill me
oh
okay I guess I'll go get it from the
vending machine
why was this bottle of pills in my room
bubbles drink sure
thank you
what oh
water water wait what water how
I'm not gonna drink out of the toilet
okay there must have been like some
water in my room that I could have
gotten that wasn't the toilet
I'm not there's no sink here so
oh
I'm so dumb sorry everybody I'm so dumb
I apologize lexian please make me look
smarter please I'm begging you make me
look better than that thank you
you always do right by me
appreciate
wow unless you didn't
okay do I feel better now
do I go to bed what the hell just
happened
I'm sorry
what
oh hi
hello oh my God go away
hello
oh my God
oh my God go away
I don't know
go away
hello I'm not here I'm not here I'm not
here
I'm gonna go to bed I'm in bed
I keep thinking that hype it's ringing
is
the door like unlock chime or something
it's better now this better not open the
door you know what I mean
who is it please open the door I need
help what do you want I need your help
please please open the door nope
nope
nope I know you're in there sure you do
oh my God
nope
I don't wanna
what
please leave
I just need to talk to you I swear I'm
not a cop please go away or I'm going to
call the cops
pretty lady oh my God no
none of that
you said that right now
what do I do do I go here in here
[Music]
what do I do
[Applause]
God what dude what huh
what was I supposed to do where are you
gonna drop me please don't be bomb Oh my
God God come on man
you made such a good scary game you're
gonna break it on the auto save
I'll be back
oh ah
well lucky for me I don't think that's
at my actual microphone but also why
it's
it's tied to my system volume but that's
how loud the game is
oh boy
I'm glad I found this before
I got to this point because I would have
been blabbering my mouth all over the
place and I would have died again and I
would have to reset all this I'm Gonna
Keep you lower
I'm Gonna Keep you a bit lower so you
don't trip
all right anyway sorry I'm still getting
back to where I was I had to take a
snack break
and a de-angering break
oh the phone's ringing this time
interesting
interesting well back to bed
is that
that actually
okay
who is it Joe from front desk open the
door I'll open the door
didn't I specifically tell you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah follow me we're almost
back
I never did try anything else in this so
if you guys try this game check some of
these other doors they probably lead to
your demise but what if they don't go
back now you got it buddy I don't know
if for some strange reason when I get
into that closet if the microphone is
going to
suddenly changed to my real microphone I
don't know
like what if the audio was louder than
it should be right
can't trust that I really have no other
way because I know that it's going to my
default microphone and because I have a
go XLR it's defaulting into my broadcast
stream mix but I don't have my
microphone on that because I separate
them for recording purposes
just in case
oh God it happened
oh hi
oh hi
okay
I'm gonna turn the volume down now they
seem to make it easier on you just in
case I don't want to go through this
again
it didn't feel safe going out
who is it
what do you want
no
no I know you're in there okay now we're
going down
okay
just in case
okay
please go away or I'm gonna call the
cops
okay okay
oh my God
[Music]
okay
everyone talking a really harsh voice
this guy has broken into my hotel room
amiding in
I am going to jump out and punch him in
the dick
repeatedly
until he passes away from dick blows not
that kind
of these kinds
that could not this kind of high
oh
you got him good good job
to this day I find it really weird that
the manager inferred not to get police
involved as it would have affected
motel's reputation and let go of the
situation I believe that the town could
have been home to a cult or a drug ring
or possibly something even worse Tommy
arrived with the car after what felt
like a year and I never went on Long
Road Trips Again
would always take airplanes
I was that close to the I
[Music]
I like the game I like it it's just the
problem of a really great atmosphere
that actually does impose a sense of
dread gets broken up and the experience
becomes disjointed when you have to
replay because the replay doesn't have
the same sense of dread that's all I'm
saying so for the next episode please
developer this game
put in a better auto save system or uh
in fact like I didn't know to go in the
closet because I had previously opened
the closet and died from it therefore I
was averse in terms of gameplay to go to
the closet it was not my instinct if
there's an innate sense of curiosity
that I had from hearing something from
the closet and opening it even if it
could have been bad and I want to be
able to experience those kinds of scares
but if it's an educational system that's
based on like you need to figure out the
choices I assumed I could blockade the
door to the bathroom as well as I could
a flimsy door to the closet now
admittedly One auto save is better than
like having go all the way back to the
beginning of the game however still was
arduous considering the only gameplay
leading up to that point was me carrying
my bags back and forth not exactly
thrilling and the few moments that there
were of scares in between robbed because
of that now I want to be very clear this
is good you've got some kind of recipe I
don't know what happened to the English
language halfway through I'm assuming
it's not your first language or the
story is not the first language there's
a language toggle here so I'm assuming
that it's not the original thing that's
fine I like I'm not I don't really care
about that like whatever but uh from a
game play standpoint make whatever
choices you want about the game in the
scare because it works just a better
audience
that's it I would love to play the next
one so anyway thank you let me know what
you guys thought down in the comments
below if you play this and find any
secrets let me know as well
thanks again check out more scary games
that I've played through the link in the
description below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]